um you guys I am so excited I watched
her movie last night how did you
approach her performances because it's
this beautiful film about life and death
and love and all the big heavy beautiful
themes that we're so lucky enough to
experience for as long as we get to
experience but it is not heavy and dark
how did you approach that there's such a
beauty and a delight throughout the film
I think we so as our kind of Bible we
had this incredible book Mike Luciano's
Memoir yeah and that was such a guide
for us and the and and the and the the
book is shot through you with so much
humor as well yeah they were really this
like playful yes they they had a dynamic
between them that was very unique to
them which is so true to life everybody
paints these pictures like it's the Last
Supper you know it's oh who wants to
watch that for two hours not me no thank
you I want to see life and love and joy
and the biggest
so immaculate I can't wait to talk about
it
um but first I was talking with Gail
King in the news and
um I'm always nudging her about dating
and I'm like if we're out at an event
the men there are not going to ask you
out in person they're all waiting to
leave the event to go home and get
rejected or accepted on some app
is that true I believe that I haven't
been asked out in person in
years I I my husband and I got together
before I think there were some apps and
there were some websites but we talk
about it all the time that I feel I feel
very grateful that they weren't as
prevalent before we met because
I'm like you I don't know what I would
be doing I don't it it's hard to
navigate love in the modern world so you
met your husband will you tell me about
how you met and you're I will
um yes uh we had his boss where he was
working was close friends with a an
actress who I went to grad school with
and um they were like oh I know somebody
oh I know somebody really yeah which may
have just been some sort of gay
generalization actually like I know a
gay guy I know a gay guy I don't know
boy it worked they um they set us up on
a blind date and they went with us when
we met at a pool hall
um I'm not sure I'm not good at it but I
do enjoy hitting the ball
um I uh but uh then we went to a karaoke
bar and the first song he sang with all
of us there was the shares I finally
found someone oh my God
oh
so that was it that was the first date
and
was it like if you karaoke you go to an
Alanis Morissette I do that list yes and
I have no shame about that it was the
first ever record I owned and I would
anything on that on Jagged Little Pill
but ironic would probably be my first my
first choice well what like for you
you're single right okay me too like
what is a red flag to you red flag I
think my thing is that I get I think
like everything's a red flag so so I'll
be like oh my God is that red flag is
that a red flag like examples like like
um it can be it can be okay so red flag
I have experienced is someone ordering
in insistently ordering my food for me a
restaurant being like you're eating this
I did carry on dating him so it wasn't
that is the reddest flag of all but you
were like let's do it again oh is this
sexy it was a little it was a
controlling yeah
um okay Jim is it true that you took
media meteorology
in college yes I had a weather
Fascination when I was young we lived on
the Gulf Coast and we would get
hurricanes and I found them fat we went
through Hurricane Alicia in 1983 was the
one that really I was like it was a big
event and I found it fascinating and so
I thought maybe I maybe I'm interested
in weather apparently I'm not that is
the only class I've ever failed and I've
come to realize I was like oh I just
liked the drama the way that they named
them is if it's some sort of Disney
creature Ursula out there it's always
going to come ashore and whatever
they're always named after women as well
not anymore
because that would sound like drag
queens well Alicia yeah raging ashore
yes okay we have to run to a quick
commercial I want to come right back and
talk about my favorite new movie your
movie is so beautiful it is so powerful
and it is master class and how to tell a
story and I do think that it is very
telling for who we should pick as
partners in life um it's called spoiler
alert
[Music]